yeah yeah exactly
[Music]
all right here we go
that leroy let's see if what i said
comes to pass because i can tell you
right now that up close that up close
game from leroy is not as easy to take
advantage of
from alisa because he has so many good
tools let's see and the stage is mad
small too
let's see if we can get these
predictions started for top eight man
but yo chat let me let me know who you
guys are going for let me know who you
guys are going for
do we got dion gray oh we got yagami who
are you guys cheering for what a big
launcher coming from your gummy already
though
this is a strong start for himself 50
health lead right now from the get-go
make that 80 health lead
oh
this is a very strong startup from
yagami no joke
let's see if you can maintain this there
you go he's warming up the old beetles
are coming out
it sticks into the wall
gets nice wall pressure what's the wake
up there it is now there's this back
three yeah
back to the whale that's right down back
four didn't work out goes for the low
chainsaws oh usually beijing gets the
wall bounce and the rage on deck two so
that means this is definitely doable and
the orbital like i said before
yes exactly shutting him down
let's say won a pace now
keeping him in check
there you go down forward one
damn this hammerhead thing just hit so
hard oh yeah
apart from like that random scream in
the ear that you get sometimes and you
freak out the top of the tree
the chocobo yeah
they gotta know that's the lore bro you
gotta know that yeah i heard i know i'm
like oh that's a chuggable
in the world of tech and i never thought
i'd see the day
i know i
even this song slaps i was actually i
was thinking literally the same thing
while standing too uh uh
oh nice it's a carry right there with
that
that hermit stands extended oh bounce
yeah
big daddy kane's out getting a full oh
no he drops the combo
down four one there it is down back
i'm surprised we haven't seen much
shotgun counter hit
on the second hit of that 4-4 yeah he
might just keep that in the pocket for
later why don't we throw all these uh
choices right now that he's got the
advantage
right now
your gummy backing up down back oh dude
wow
dude yagami's popping off right now dude
and theon grey
he needs to get into gear right now
that was that was left to the wire it's
like too uncomfortable how close that
match was wow that was good but from
both sides
lots of swinging coming from both of
them in all honesty i like the offense
coming from elisa though towards the end
there i was expecting but i'm gonna tell
you right now i'm gonna tell you right
now i was expecting a little more
offensive retaliation coming from leroy
we didn't we only saw one orbital i
thought that was going to be the
beginning of it because that's what i'm
looking for i'm looking for the shotguns
i'm looking for the wildstanding twos
i'm looking for the four two twos though
those are the tools that leroy likes to
use up close to keep people honest even
an elisa who seems a little bit over
what she seems like she can overwhelm
you pretty easy with the chainsaw
pressure we saw the side step uh come in
with the automatic evasion and got the
wall belts i'm thinking that we're going
to see that get slowed down to a pace
where it's going to be controllable but
it's not because we're not seeing any
challenges coming from leroy so that's
what we need to see that's one of the
things that needs to change because they
were just swinging at each other and
elisa definitely she knows how to
function in the scramble
yeah yeah definitely and i i usually
find that dion's playstyle is a little
bit more aggressive like what you were
kind of expecting i was expecting as
well
he's usually just poking you and has
that one poke advantage on top of you
he's like always one like almost one
frame ahead so you can't really go for
it at any time that's how he likes to
play he likes to be in your head
but um he definitely has several
characters they may fall back to just in
case he doesn't he feels off like i
remember back in season three days
um a very common thing that dion would
say like he backed this was season two
when he was traveling and you know world
tours and all that used to be playing
geese back then all right
and yeah i forgot about it
yeah so he was playing geese but he
would say if i'm in tournament and all
of a sudden i'm not executing right i'm
just feeling off it could happen between
matches not necessarily you have a bad
day but you just might have a bad match
you will fall back to other characters
like for example jack that's his
original season one character but the
fact that he stuck with leroy means that
he he knows that he can get the job done
and he's not feeling off just a matter
of approach at this point
let's see how he's going to play it out
arenas
there's the orbital this is exactly what
i was talking about oh big damage here
ah
orbital again like i said resetting the
scaling dude another one
counting down that's it beautifully done
i'm gonna get the combo i like this i
like this borderline perfect borderline
perfect there you go
the back four didn't find his mark
you got me trying to slow it down a
little bit goes back to the folks tries
the early sides to have good block and
what did i say
once we started seeing the shotguns this
is how leroy controls a neutral game
even versus a character like alisa the
back four catches him trying to sidestep
there's a down back three against the
wall this is great okay look at this
he's in the gear right now
and this is when you want to see elisa
start playing that that
play back a little bit what ya got me is
doing
beyond turning up the defense though
down back four is one of the main tools
using to open up the game
down four four no in the hermit stands
and just yagami just playing back not
trying to mess with it get the counter
hit back four uh
oh i like the combo extension to the
wall look at the damage oh my god
yeah welcome to dion land this is it
the big triple no d9 okay cool cool
chainsaws are out oh i like this
advantage of the chainsaws
with the blue stuff you got them in the
chat i know we got some taste buds in
the chat and we got taste buds chat let
me see your blue stuff i know you got
them blue stuff right now
and this these hermit mix-ups are really
starting to get the best that you got me
right now dion gray just holding hermes
stands oh yeah
up whiffs good ah don't ever extend like
that
be very dangerous
okay so it looks like yagami's trying to
like with a side step he's trying to
create an opportunity oh no ahead today
boy
no thanks no thanks
no no no
hold the low parry
oh [ __ ]
again that race drive
and that's gonna be enough yagami can
still steal this set dion gray was
looking like a game was coming but uh
oh big daddy kane denied
oh big
chainsaws okay good block
nice with the low parry
okay that should get him to the wall
let's see how he's gonna fold this up
he's gonna maintain his pressure there
you go
very nice
the it man there it is
dion gray holds the hermit stance to let
you know it wasn't a fluke we got one
more game in the set but that's exactly
what i was looking for to come to for
this set we were talking about what
needed to be done for leroy to get back
control right and what exactly what i
was thinking i'm like look if we start
seeing shotguns even alisa is gonna have
to back up a little bit those orbitals
in that first round second game really
set the pace we got like two rounds
instantly just by using orbital against
the wall
yeah yeah it's like it makes you
second-guess yourself especially the
shotguns where you think okay now it now
now boom and you're over it's over it's
like oh that's playing yoshimitsu like
when you think that like okay these are
my opportunities these are my responses
well that's what they're waiting for
it's like where i've developed this
instinct to just pop you for every time
you think that you got the advantage
so yeah as you said it just pretty much
played out as you predicted and it's
going to be interesting to see how
yagami yagami's gonna respond to that
because even in this match it was almost
over he almost took that so he's not
that far off from the answer if that
makes sense but he's just gonna create
more opportunities for himself yeah yeah
it's it's more about it it's looking at
the what we're seeing here you can you
can answer back like you said um they
definitely made it so alyssa can be a
lot more
she could be a lot more aggressive in
the neutral now even versus some of
these characters you got to play back a
little bit and respect the range of a
lydia of a leroy even like a [ __ ] ram
is one of those characters that she has
to like play back a little bit but it's
still there she can definitely turn on
the offense we saw it a little bit with
the chainsaw pressure because dion was
not reacting the right way and a lot of
instances and even if it wasn't big
damage or a combo that came from it just
the lows that we see come from that
hermit stamp come from chainsaw stands
really does add up
let's see if the infinite stage is going
to make that difference
there's one thing that um leeroy is good
at is gap closing like he can have a big
distance from you but he'll just like
shut you off with a big whiff punish
and analysis movement uh on a stage like
this can really take her apart
especially with the side steps that's
exactly what i was talking about not
having to worry about some of that wall
pressure that leroy's going to be able
to get coming from these big counties
like shotgun
oh special you gotta respect the space
and no tech there means you're gonna get
the follow-up what about wow i didn't
see the follow-up coming i like the
choice from yugami though
yeah that was good that was good
okay so jagami's got the lead now
just two rounds that's all he needs
down jab backs up a little bit you got
me going to that chainsaw stance this is
exactly what i was talking about you can
see your gummy playing back at like that
range two range three and the side steps
adding up too
oh yeah
there we go maintaining pressure going
mid
you can force some sort of counter hit
out of them
downpour okay that's why yeah this
challenges him right once he goes into
stance just to immediately challenge it
no good break
yeah break on the normal throw oh okay
okay
that's how you know yagami is awake
blocks both hits didn't even take the
punish just like i just want you to know
that i'm in your head right now
yeah i'm just randomly blocking
okay oh it's anyone nice response five
seconds
wow
round three okay
in this third game two rounds on set
point here
winner semis
still best of three
oh orbital
oh yo they hit on the race drop
oh get crushed on kid
okay this is very good scenario for
yagami right now
he's gonna tank it no
no ralph brown
knocked out the flushed yagami
pushing himself right through winner's
side
unreal unreal
that was crazy go to the losers side
gonna go down on the lower bracket side
of things because that was definitely
winners uh damn three rounds to